[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
sur france 3 bourgogne franche comté
alors que la politique du gouvernement
dans l'impression de pencher à droite
des députés macro nist essentiellement
venues du parti socialiste cherche à
peser en interne pour porter une voix
plus sociale au sein de la majorité
alors la politique du gouvernement
d'edouard philippe penche t elle
véritablement à droite la majorité des
manuels macron peut-elle marcher sur ses
deux jambes la droite et la gauche
y at il des mesures qualifiées de gauche
dans les projets du gouvernement pour
2018 la gauche socialiste aurait-elle
fait une autre politique et laquelle on
en débat ce matin avec mes invités
cécile untermaier bonjour je vous êtes
député nouvelle gauche de saône et loire
à leur nouvelle gauche c'est le groupe
du parti socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale merci d'être avec nous et eric
alauzet bonjour vous êtes député la
république en marche du doubs merci à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté cette
invitation en direct ce dimanche matin
vous qui nous regarde et vous pouvez
bien sûr commenter cette émission sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag dit
mme paul dfc comme dimanche en politique
bourgogne franche comté alors eric
alauzet c'est à vous que je pose la
première question vous l'écologiste
ancien membre d'europe écologie les
verts donc plutôt classé à gauche
théoriquement même si vous me direz très
vite que l'écologie c'est pas seulement
de gauche
quel regard est ce que vous portez sur
ses deux jambes de la majorité est ce
que honnêtement il sans langue de bois
on sait pas qui en a une qui est un
petit peu plus musclée que l'autre c'est
qu'ils arrivent dans le corps humain
aussi docteur j'avais 10 ans et le monde
c'est la planète qui vire à droite et la
communauté internationale et vers le
libéralisme c'est une tendance lourde
depuis les années thatcher reagan
prendre 40 ans donc c'est difficile de
résister à ce mouvement
il faudra regarder mesure pas monsieur
parce que je pense que les français ils
n'ont pas trop envie de savoir si ces
droite ou de gauche ils doivent savoir
quel impact concret ça assure sur leur
vie mais votre question est extrêmement
pertinente parce que ce débat il reste
tout à fait légitime que je simplifie en
nylon à la tension entre l'individu que
la droite traite plutôt et le collectif
que la gauche très tôt de son côté et
c'est un équilibre permanent entre les
deux et vous avez raison de le dire qui
va de plus en plus vers l'individu
vers le comment dire cette liberté
absolue que qui devrait tout régir et
l'économie en particulier vous ne me
répondez pas comme beaucoup de membres
de la majorité
c'est un débat ancien monde maintenant
c'est le moment la droite et la gauche
ça n'existe non non pas du tout il ya
différentes façons de voir la droite et
la gauche la question de l'europe par
exemple qui pourrait qu'ils pourraient
fracturé la droite et la gauche mais
c'est principalement je lis cette
évolution du moins ce qu'il faut et
contrecarrer le discours du président la
république à davos est extrêmement
éclairant de ce point de vue là il y en
en gros en france on est dans la
compétition mondiale
il faut peu ou prou s'y adapter mais
mondialement au niveau de l'europe en
particulier il faut essayer de maîtriser
de contrôler cette dérive libérale sinon
on va perdre toutes nos valeurs et les
inégalités vont croître
c'est cette tension permanente qui
précéderait après faut regarder les
mesures concrètes alors on va en venir
aux mesures concrètes ceci nous temps
meilleurs vous quel est votre regard sur
cette majorité des manuels macron que
vous côtoyez presque quotidiennement à
l'assemblée nationale est-ce que lé plus
de gauche plus de droite comment vous la
regardez écoutez cette majorité doit ce
qui est assez symptomatique c'est qu'on
sent des députés qui doivent tous en
fête qui doivent leur élection à
emmanuel macron et qui de ce fait sont
bien sûr dans la main d'un exécutif qui
fait peser sa vision et sa démarche très
manifestement je pense sans tabou parce
qu'il ya des tabous à gauche il ya des
tabous à droite
manifestement
la politique qui est menée est une
politique sur la jambe de droite
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas voté le budget 2010 8 parce
qu'il ne correspondait pas nous
semble-t-il à l'ardente nécessité que
nous avons de réduire les inégalités de
repenser la question du service public
et les désordres sociaux que nous avons
constatée dernièrement
hélas semble nous donner raison alors on
va y venir évidemment mais est ce qu'il
ya des mesures du gouvernement de
l'homme de droite à edouard philippe qui
trouve grâce à vos yeux aux yeux du
parti socialiste depuis ses premiers
mois de la législature est ce que vous
en voyez depuis le mois de juin est ce
qu'il ya des choses que vous auriez
voter ou que vous avez voté qui vous
semblent pertinentes
oui bien sûr moi j'ai voté et mon groupe
aussi nous avons voté la loi sur la
confiance c'était une loi indispensable
ce n'est pas une loi révolutionnaire
parce que nous avions déjà avancer dans
cette direction mais il y avait un
besoin de clarification
je pars notamment des indemnités des
parlementaires qui sont maintenant sous
contrôle mais qui n'ont pas dit
d'ailleurs diminué essais et c'est très
bien
je pense à la réserve parlementaire qui
avait maman sens un clientélisme si nous
ne prenions pas nous la peine de mettre
en place des jurys citoyens donc cette
loi sur la confiance en était d'ailleurs
responsable pour mon groupe nous l'avons
voté sans hésitation même si nous
considérons que
les associations sont les grandes
perdantes de ce dispositif
nous avons voté dernièrement le droit à
l'erreur parce qu'effectivement dans
l'administration on parlera sans doute
des services publics
il nous faut nous innover nous rénové
revoir le logiciel et les services
publics mais certainement pas le droit à
l'erreur
le droit à l'erreur nous l'avons voté le
budget nous ne l'avons pas voter vous le
savez sans doute pourquoi c'est d'abord
la la suppression de l'impôt sur la
fortune
parce que nous considérons qu'il y avait
par cet impôt qui représente quand même
5 milliards le moyen d'aller au soutien
de services qui sont en souffrance je
pense au présent je pense aux ehpad je
pense aux hôpitaux et à la nécessaire
importance à donner à l'éducation
mais justement on parler d'éducation la
limitation du nombre d'élèves par classe
dans les secteurs difficiles où la fin
de la taxe d'habitation sont des choses
qui pourraient sembler plus de gauche
non moi je souscris à l'idée de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
je pense que et je trouve que un pas a
été fait sans doute sous notre impulsion
c'est de dire que cette taxe
d'habitation puisque c'est un impôt
injuste supprimons le pour tout le monde
y compris pour les 20% qui doivent
encore la payer et qui vont ce qu'ils se
retrouveraient dans une situation un peu
particulière au sein d'une collectivité
alors je vous propose de parler dans un
instant seulement de la fiscalité
eric alauzet mais ce mercredi
l'actualité c'est que le gouvernement a
présenté un projet de loi censé mettre
fin à la guerre des prix entre
distributeurs et redonner un peu d'air à
nos agriculteurs français ça passe
notamment
vous le savez par la fin des promotions
qualifiée d'excessive par le
gouvernement alors bon pour les
agriculteurs mais pas forcément pour le
portefeuille des français non eric
alauzet est ce que là on est dans la
mesure de gauche pas l'idée c'est que ce
soit neutre pour les français mais les
prix ont beaucoup augmenté depuis 30 ans
pour les consommateurs et les
agriculteurs n'ont quasiment rien
récupéré son ensemble des intermédiaires
de la grande distribution il faut dire
qu'il a récupéré l'ensemble des marges
donc l'idée là c'est de répartir la
valeur entre les paysans et les
intermédiaires de façon à ce que ce soit
neutre pour les habitants est-ce qu'on
va y arriver ou pas l'idée c'est de
prendre en compte dans le prix dans la
formation des prix
le coût de production des agriculteurs
alors vous avez ceux qui vont pas trop
mal qui sont sur des niches des aoc
dans ce conte est évident filières de
distribution directe et puis il ya ceux
qui sont sur les marchés mondiaux et
cela il faut les aider
d'une part à muter quand ils le peuvent
à se dégager de la mondialisation et
pour les ceux qui sont qui resteront
dans la mondialisation et qui n'ont pas
le choix effectivement à ce que la
répartition de la valeur entre le
producteur le paysan et les
distributeurs soient plus favorables aux
paysans mais je pense aux familles qui
nous regardent à ceux qui achètent un
produit ou un autre faire on voit
beaucoup dans nos magasins ça le
gouvernement n'en veut plus y compris
quand c'est pas des produits
d'agriculteurs français allez je vais
prendre un exemple ma capsules de café
et qui n'a rien à voir avec le
producteur français qui par ailleurs n'a
souvent rien à voir avec une entreprise
française c'est plutôt du côté de la
suisse souvent que ça se passe quand
j'achète une boîte acheter une boîte
offert dans mon supermarché
eh bien je fais des économies quand même
c'est très net
est-ce que ça va pas impacter le pouvoir
d'achat des français oui mais est
ensuite j'entends des solutions il faut
quand même que la question de
l'alimentation deviennent un enjeu
national est une priorité ou savait que
la part de l'alimentation dans notre
poule dans notre dépense s'est réduite
et ça il faut que vraiment on re
apprennent à retrouver la qualité et si
on retrouve la qualité c'est pour notre
santé c'est pour l'environnement c'est
pour les paysans donc il ya des
questions d' équilibre de pouvoir
d'achat a retrouvé bien évidemment mais
il faut qu'on parle des mesures des
pouvoirs d'achat là parce que c'est là
que ça se joue principalement alors on
va y venir évidemment c'est si longtemps
mayer cette loi ce projet de loi
alimentation comment vous l'analysez
vous alors il est des îles a été déposée
le 31 janvier en conseil des ministres
je pense que c'est un une loi qui
s'inscrit bien sûr dans les états
généraux bien nommé de l'alimentation
auquel quand même nicolas hulot n'a pas
souhaité manifester son intérêt et son
adhésion parce qu'on était en deçà de la
démarche que nous voulions avoir je
pense que les écologistes sont derrière
nous à ce sujet la loi va dans le bon
sens ce que vous avez dit moi je suis
complètement d'accord il faut
effectivement le 10 % de seuil de
revente la limitation de la promotion
c'est tout à fait essentiel je pense que
nous allons souscrire sur ce point en
revanche il y à une question et je pense
qu'on pourrait nous l'assemblée si nous
sommes vraiment à une assemblée discuter
de cela
la question c'est les grandes surfaces
la grande distribution moi je ne fais
pas confiance à la grande distribution
je ne pense pas qu'on arrivera à la
halla halla halla régulé au point
qu'elle satisfasse aux exigences
légitimes du paysan qui veut bien sûr
vives de sa production
et c'est là où je considère qu'il nous
faudrait mettre le citoyen dans la
boucle
c'est à dire imaginez une traçabilité
sur la transparence des marges et sur le
coût auquel on a acheté le produit qui a
été fabriqué cela ça fait depuis 2012
que que je tente de poser cette question
et je tends la main à mon collègue pour
que nous puissions ensemble réfléchir à
cela
mais on aime manger la pression dans les
courses dans les mêmes magasins que moi
il va y avoir un impact sur le
portefeuille des ménages non bien sûr
qui aura un impact sur le portefeuille
des ménages mais il faut là là aussi
avoir de la pédagogie
peut-être faut-il acheter moins acheter
mieux est l'enjeu d'une qualité
d'alimentation saine nous renvoie à une
agriculture saine biologique et il est à
mon sens tout à fait essentiel d'aller
dans cette voie et j'insiste sur l'idée
du prix citoyen promettons le citoyen
comme arbitre de sable de consommateurs
et et arbitre entre une grande
distribution qui détruit une agriculture
et qui donc touche à son porte-monnaie
de citoyen qui paye ses impôts et des
producteurs qui ont besoin de nous parce
que nous aimons les agriculteurs qui
produisent des produits de qualité -
eric alauzet on a bien senti la petite
pique sur nicolas hulot qui qui n'a pas
vraiment apprécié un ces états généraux
de l'alimentation on peut le dire comme
ça vous l'accord agissent
qu'est ce que vous dites est pas
totalement abouti au niveau de ce
moment-là et du rendu compte du travail
qui avait été fait mais le travail se
poursuit dans les specs nicolas hulot la
semaine dernière les choses vont avancer
et à certains moments il faut affirmer
sa volonté faut affirmer son identité il
l'a fait à ce moment là et ça va lui
permettre d'avancer
vous entendez la main tendue aussi via
ses meilleurs jeunes sujets sur lesquels
on se retrouve bien entendu
alors on va passer sur les sujets qui
fâchent peut-être plus directement parce
que dans l'actualité de ces derniers
jours gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics a évoqué
ce jeudi l'idée d'un plan de départs
volontaire pour les fonctionnaires qui
souhaiteraient partir en raison
notamment de la réforme de l'état qui
s'engagera dans les prochaines années
une forme de guichet au départ ce serait
une première dans la fonction publique
est ce que vous êtes à l'aise eric
alauzet avec cette idée qu'il faut moins
de fonctionnaires avec cette idée qu'on
met un guichet de départs dans la
fonction publique
vous allez lol écologistes de gauche on
va dire pour moi j'ai été basculés sur
beaucoup de sujets c'est la forme d'une
est ce que quand vous êtes quand même
comme pardon nicolas hulot est ce que
vous avaler beaucoup de couleuvres et
beaucoup de chapeaux mais c'est en
permanence des débats je pense que cette
période là elle extrêmement bénéfique
parce qu'elle fait elle donne une
respiration à la vie démocratique
les partis politiques c'est bien ça
construit des politiques cohérentes en
même temps sans ferme hélas cette
période et je vous ferai les fenêtres
enfin bouffée d'oxygène et moi même j'ai
été obligé de m'interroger sur internet
certains le sujet on aura peut-être le
temps d'en parler
celui que vous évoquez un instant de la
suppression du nombre de fonctionnaires
ceci dit ça a été largement évoqué
pendant la campagne
c'était au tour de 100000 pour emmanuel
macron c'était vous souvenez cinq cent
mille pour cent sept films que vous
demandez la différence entre la droite
et la gauche qu il se soit assagi un peu
à 300 milles mais quand même il ya une
sacrée différence
donc le monde évolue la fonction
publique va évoluer aussi c'est
inévitable c'est le début du débat pour
l'instant donc j'ai pas me prononcer sur
les effets d'annoncé qui ont été faits
on verra on va travailler on verra
qu'elle utilise la seule annonce de
votre gouvernement d'assurer ce c'est un
a passablement cd et fait grandir
l'idée qu'on allait réduire sans me le
demande aux fonctionnaires sur cinq
millions c'est pas nouveau
c'est alors qu'on le savait on savait
qu'il y aurait une diminution du nombre
de fonctionnaires du coup ça nous
surprend pas cécile untermaier annonce
était attendue et je pense que emmanuel
macron a bien l'intention de faire ce
qu'il a dit et en ce sens moi je
comprends qu'il ait cette démarche ceci
dit sur moi nous on a toujours manifesté
notre notre notre volonté de maintenir
ce niveau de fonctionnaires actuellement
non pas par souci de corporatisme mais
parce que on sait bien que les services
publics ne sont plus au niveau de ce
qu'attendent les citoyens
moi je suis ravi d'être ici dans un
service public de l'audiovisuel
je me sens bien dans votre maison parce
que je sais que c'est un service public
de l'audiovisuel dans lequel on a étudié
la déontologie dans lequel on a étudié
le problème des conflits d'intérêts donc
il s'agit pas de mettre sur un piédestal
la fonction publique je suis d'accord
avec mon collègue qu'il faut revisiter
sans tabou la fonction publique mais je
pense que l' annonce faite par ces deux
ministres de droite est une annonce
violente au regard des quand même de
l'inquiétude actuelle des fonctionnaires
qui n'ont pas vu le qui ont une baisse
de pouvoir d'achat et qui est violente
par rapport à cette difficulté d'être
dans des ehpad des hôpitaux et donc je
pense que on peut lever qu'un volontaire
est important et je pense qu'il faut
qu'on mettre du temps sur cette question
parce qu'elle est importante
pourquoi pas le départ volontaire mais
le départ volontaire il faut d'abord
qu'ils soient vraiment volontaires
si c'est pour le faire partir pour
mettre un contractuel privé qui sera
dans la main de l'employeur parce que
c'est ça aussi la fonction publique
s'activent déjà dans la fonction
publique c'est le charme et noël des
contrats de trois ans renouvelables
voilà mais c'est de cela ça sera autre
chose je pense donc il faut qu'on
réfléchisse c'est ça mais je suis bien
persuadé qu'à l'assemblée nationale nous
réfléchirons quand même à cette loi sur
la déontologie des fonctionnaires que
nous avons voté ensemble en avril 2016
j'ai su répondre aux jeunes il ya déjà
20 % à peu près de contractuels dans
l'ensemble des fonctions publiques
donc ça existe déjà j'ai pas si à la fin
du mandat il honora 22-23 jeu peut-être
j'en sais rien la baisse de la dépense
publique cécile on a fait beaucoup au
mandat précédent + 30 milliards d'euros
on a baissé le nombre de fonctionnaires
donc c'est un mouvement de deux fonds
est partout à nos amis les il y en a pas
qui on a vu surgir et le point d'indicé
des fonctionnaires ces embauches et des
policiers fait soignons nos gens dans
les épreuves et non les policiers on les
a renforcés et des gendarmes les reds en
force' à peu près à hauteur des 10000
dans l'axé ça que vous allez payer ses
fonctionnaires alors que ça avait été
baissé à l'époque de nicolas sarkozy et
il est prévu encore de les augmenter
dans ce mandat là 2000 parents et aussi
pour les prisons qu'elles fourniront
parle d'après vous il ya eu beaucoup de
fonctionnaires dans l'est dans les
fonctions envahir de support tout ce qui
est informatique secrétariat liste
raconte gestion et en danse etc
voilà donc la baiser en public elle est
en route et pour autant il y avait aussi
les sf existait pour autant d'appareils
l'épreuve des ehpad on appareils ne
prennent des hôpitaux un appareil les
prennent des retraites
on a donc n'essayez pas de faire croire
qu'avec 3 5 milliards d'euros
on aurait réglé près même si on les a
pas réglé quand
dsf donc c'est pas la suppression isf
qui va permettre de les régler et voilà
il faut qu'on parle d'une mesure de
pouvoir d'achat parce qu'il ya des
mesures de puisque vous la question
c'est droite-gauche taxe d'habitation la
suppression des taxes d'habitation et
une mesure s'il faut se classer une
radio comme les qualifie de gauche oui
pour la raison très simple pression de
la classe moyenne
quelle serait sa glace en moyenne entre
le 4e et 8e missiles et les plus aisés
continuer à le payer
et là surprise c'est une loggia soit oui
oui tout à fait tout à fait je vous
explique l'augmentation la cg et la
baisse des cotisations sociales
salariales
c'est une mesure de voler deux en même
temps à les deux en même temps
l'augmentation de la csg par exemple les
fonctionnaires et les retraités venons
chaque catégorie à vue renan chaque
catégorie pour les salariés c'est une
augmentation savoir d'achat net pour les
fonctionnaires ces étals mais les
fonctionnaires quand on est faible
revenu voir la prime pour l'activité et
à la fin du mois et la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation aussi et les retraités qui
gagne 1500 euros par mois de retraite
est trop vite si on n'a pas le temps de
dire en des gens comprendront pas mais
pour les salariés du public qui servit
au smic ou un peu plus qu 1,3 smic
cette année à la fin de l'année il aura
40 euros par mois en plus et à la fin du
mandat
110 euros par mois alors que cécile
untermaier est d'accord et pouvoir
d'achat des mesures de gauche et en plus
ces nouvelles façons de financer la
sécurité sociale plus universel par la
csg par l'impôt et les revenus du
capital ça c'est de gauche
les revenus du capital finance la
protection sociale quant à l' isf c'est
un effondrement de nos entreprises et
nos autres nos entreprises de taille
intermédiaire les ceux qui détenaient le
capital des familles notamment se sont
vendus sont aller placer leur argent à
l'étranger et on a deux fois trois fois
moins de technique les allemands on a
plus de robots en france c'est une vraie
catastrophe pour notre économie avec une
barrière mayer doivent de réagir parce
qu'on a bien entendu là le discours du
gouvernement et la république en marche
- est-ce que vous que vous faites votre
assez logique oui mais bon sur l'impôt
sur la fortune moi j'ai pas envie de
faire cette bataille de chiffres
bon voilà on en est c'est vrai qu hier
j'avais un conseil citoyen quelqu'un qui
gagne le smic m'a dit c'est bien dans ma
feuille de paye le gagne 7 euros de plus
par mois et je suis content et je suis
content de cela mais c'est vrai aussi
j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de me dire que
l'impôt sur la fortune avait fait 48
mille euros 2,2 d'économies notre
ministre du travail qui s'empresse de
dire ensuite mais attendez je vais le
placer ne vous inquiétez pas il ira
alimenter
l'ex inconnu mis tout ça n'est pas très
très sérieux me semble-t-il mais je ne
veux pas discuter sur cela je suis
d'accord pour la taxe d'habitation je
suis d'accord pour une cg mais pas sur
un niveau de seuil de 2200 euros pour
les retraités
je pense par ailleurs que l s'agit que
je voudrais revenir quand même sur la
question de la fonction publique parce
que je ne voudrais pas qu'on considère
que nous sommes dans une défense de
corporatisme et qu'on veut rien changer
je crois qu'au contraire nous avons
montré notre volonté d'aller en qualité
dans la fonction publique et il faut
revisiter cette question de la fonction
publique je suis d'accord mais pas par
une annonce comme celle ci est une
annonces anxiogènes et qui à l'empreinte
du goût du dégagisme quoi on vous a
entendu si vous n'êtes pas content de ce
que vous voulez pas écouter la porte
vous est ouverte et puis on vous fera un
chèque en partant moi je crois qu'il ya
des vrais questions qui se posent dans
la fonction publique et notamment nous
nous devons et je pense qu emmanuel
macron est en capacité de le faire c'est
de revisiter la haute administration
parce qu'on ne parle pas beaucoup de la
haute administration et de sa capacité à
partir dans le privé à revenir ensuite
c'est ce qu'on appelle le pantouflage
avec le problème des réseaux d'intérêts
est le problème du chèque important que
l'on que l'on a à l'entrée et à la
sortie
donc moi je suis concerné aussi les
fonds et les hauts fonctionnaires du
parlement par exemple on a beaucoup
parlé ces dernières semaines c'est une
vraie question c'est une vraie question
une question d'ouverture ce que je vais
dire quand même c'est que la fonction
publique
elle doit être revisitée moi je suis
complètement d'accord mais attention ne
considérons pas que la numérisation la
digitalisation va régler tous les
problèmes parce que je reçois et sans
doute toi aussi à ma paire nam
permanence nombre de gens qui me disent
j'essaye d'aller sur le dispositif ça
marche pas je vais à la sous-préfecture
je rencontre un service civique qui bien
évidemment me dise qu'il peut me dire
mais ne résout pas le problème
et résultat on vient me voir en me
disant est ce que tu peux faire une
question écrite en disant que la
numérisation c'est pas il faut des gens
à côté
si on veut réussir et moi je souscris à
cela la numérisation
il faut qu'on maintienne un moment
encore les agents qui sont derrière eric
alauzet répondait à ça en un mot et puis
on va passer à un autre sujet qui fait
débat
non mais on est passé traître
tout à l'heure ce point d'achat il
aurait parlé des retraités moi je veux
vraiment y revenir parce que les
retraités
si ça avait été la droite au pouvoir on
avait non pas la baisse des taxes
d'habitation qui est pour la classe
moyenne mais une baisse d'impôt sur le
revenu pourrait profiter aux plus aisés
on n'aurait pas eu la baisse des
cotisations salariales mais on aurait eu
hélas l'augmentation à siéger à la pelle
augmentation il s'agirait de
l'augmentation de tva il ne préservait
pas y compris les petits retraités
jusque là jusqu'à 1400 euros pour
arrêter ce traité seul 2200 euros pour
un couple
il n'y a pas d'augmentation assiégée et
comme y aura une baisse de taxe
d'habitation en dessous de 2500 euros
n'y aura pas de perte pour une personne
seule 3950 euros pour un couple
voilà voilà les différences entre la
droite et la gauche c'est sûr si j'ai
encore parlé de pouvoir d'achat par
contre c'est tellement il ya un autre
sujet il ya un autre sujet dans
l'actualité malheureuse cette semaine
une vingtaine de migrants ont été
blessées jeudi dans de violentes rixes
entre erythréens et afghans à calais
plusieurs ont été touchés par balles
et justement il ya un projet de loi sur
l'immigration qui fait partie des
chantiers 2018 il est porté par gérard
collomb le ministre de l'intérieur qui
ne fait pas d'ailleurs l'unanimité ce
projet de loi au sein de la majorité qui
fait même polémique auprès des
associations des représentants religieux
et puis il ya bien sûr la fameuse
circulaire de gérard collomb autour de
l'accueil inconditionnel ou pas dans les
centres de sans abri alors et décale aux
ailes là on est clairement dans un homme
de gauche qui pratique une politique qui
pourrait s'approcher de celle qu'on a
connue avec nicolas sarkozy par exemple
là encore on raisonne pas en 2000 en
2017 2018 comme on raisonnait en 2008 et
vous même les lui et sur ces questions
là par exemple
oui j'ai évolué je pense qu'il faut être
en 2010 les conflits syriens aient les
conflits en afrique qui fait qu'il ya
des mouvements sur la planète
avec le réchauffement climatique en plus
qui sont beaucoup plus importants donc
ça il faut l'intégrer et c'est vrai
qu'alors il ya deux sujets qui sont
assez faciles et un sujet au milieu qui
est compliqué les deux sujets faciles
c'est les personnes qui viennent de pays
où il ya des guerres où il risque pour
leur vie l'asile est renforcée et ces
personnes seront mieux accompagner ses
la syrie c'est l'afghanistan c'est la
libye
celle erythrée etc il ya des pays où ça
se passe l'économie n'est pas
florissante mais ya pas de guerre où les
gens sont pas en danger
donc il pas par leur liberté ii est
réservé deux du secteur en asie cg
personnes la vienne et on peut le
comprendre
on va avoir une meilleure vie mais il
n'empêche que il faut les inciter à
reconstruire leur pays
d'abord avant tout et si les politiques
de développement n'avait pas été aussi
indigente depuis des décennies peut-être
que ces pays là ce serait mieux
développer et les gens pourraient rester
chez eux donc il faut renforcer les
politiques de développement
et puis elle catégorie un peu compliqué
c'est les personnes qui sont là depuis
plusieurs années en france
un an deux ans trois ans quatre ans
parce que les recours ont été
extrêmement long et les familles se sont
installées ils ont des enfants des
réseaux de solidarité se sont créés
autour d'elle reconduit la frontière
c'est du cas par cas
ces deux cas moi j'ai accompagné plus de
150 personnes depuis quatre ans c'est du
cas par cas on peut pas généraliser ces
formats lus mais assez court parce qu'on
arrive bientôt au terme de l'émission
déjà sur cette question des migrants est
ce que vous reconnaissez l'homme de
gauche qualité gérard collomb
écoutez j'ai pas envie d'aller dans dans
les étiquettes gauche aura je crois que
là on ardennes de l'émission en tout oui
bien sûr mais je veux dire sur l'asile
et l'immigration c'est un problème
tellement complexe que l'on peut pas
dire on a une politique de gauche on est
politique de droite je pense qu'on doit
tous avoir une politique humaine et
digne pour les gens qui vivent ils
viennent sur nos territoires quel que
soit leur statut ou est ce qu'il faut
faire de différence et quel que soit
leur statut
l'accueil est indifférenciée là dessus
c'est ce qui a fait que la circulaire
que l'on a été très mal vécue et je
pense qu'on a raison et je trouve que
c'est un espoir qu'on donne à nos
valeurs c'est que on n'admet pas
l'accueil dans les centres d'hébergement
pour sans-abri bien sûr on les a on les
accueille sans se préoccuper de savoir
s'ils ont droit à un il faut le mettre à
l'abri vaudou bat il faut les mais il ya
une tradition d'accueil absolument
indispensable bien sûr mais il faut
néanmoins identifié les personnes parce
que ne ressortent pas du même parcours
selon les catégories que j'ai a indiqué
tout à l'heure et en particulier non
mais le cas précis de ce qu'on appelle
les doubles ine oui il faut revoir
dublin parce que il faut qu'un un
migrant ils puissent éventuellement
faire ses démarches dans le pays de son
choix et pas forcément pays de
frontières de l'europe mais
une fois qu'un dossier a été instruit
dans un pays que la personne ait débouté
on peut pas imaginer un instant que ces
personnes-là fasse le tour d'europe en
relançant des dossiers d'assistance
chacun des pays il ya trois cent mille
personnes qui ont été déboutés en
allemagne l'allemagne qu'on dit si
généreuse a débouté 300000 personnes
peut pas considérer que ces trois cent
mille ont relevé le centre des mérites
de son service et le lieu où on doit
régler ces questions là en doute pas
mais les gens doivent être identifiés
six puits doivent être identifiés et
dont tout le parcours dans soit les
adapter donc on est d'accord le centre
d'hébergement est un lieu
d'inconditionnalité de l'accueil et on
peut pas non mais on peut on doit avoir
on a arrêté notre politique
gesticulatoire essayons de le faire mais
en tout cas on doit accueillir de
manière digne et humaine tout nous
toutes ont une relationniste fondation
alors on va s'arrêter sur les migrants
juste en avant de conclure dans le
journal du dimanche il ya trois semaines
manuel valls déclaré ceci je vous
propose de regarder avec moi le point
d'équilibré de la majorité est au centre
gauche alors que celui de l'exécutif est
au centre droit le risque de désaccord
vient de là a expliqué l'ancien premier
ministre
d'accord pas d'accord du tout d'accord
la politique qui est menée est celle d'
emmanuel macron com - d'après ces danses
n'a jamais il admis la politique de jean
marc ayrault ni celle de manuel valls
ç'a toujours été celle de françois
hollande est compris l'inflexion la
politique qui est menée l'ensemble des
mesures dont elle a parlé sur toutes les
mesures y a pas une différence contre
les deux vous la sentez cette différence
entre faire la différence
cette analyse est sûrement la plus à
droite et la majorité
n'est ce pas forcément mais on va la
politique c'est pas les six mois qui
viennent de s'écouler
on va voir il ya de la marge pour leur
établissement on suivra bien sûr tout ça
de près merci d'avoir accepté de
répondre à ces questions de débattre en
direct ce matin et à vous de nous avoir
suivis dans un instant le point sur
l'actualité régionale avec emmanuel
pinceau depuis la partie nationale de
dimanche en politique francis letellier
reçoit le bourguignon benjamin griveaux
porte parole du gouvernement et puis
sachez que cette émission s'interrompt
quelques semaines pour laisser place aux
jeux olympiques
ar on suivra les sportifs de notre
région bon dimanche